ptoo burrs is Charlie Superbowl hype so
we've got a whole bunch of trailer stuff
is coming and they confirm that they're
making a Miles Morales movie some
explain what's going on there's a new
round of the spider-man giveaway going
on now it's a $20 comiXology gift card
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video be sure to click that Bell to
enable alerts so you don't miss anything
this is so great if you guys forgot the
Superbowl is coming up really soon so
number 10 new trailers Sony has a
history of buying Super Bowl spots for
its spider-man movies which is typically
been summer movies but usually what they
do is they buy like a 30-second spot
that'll air during the Super Bowl and
then they'll post something longer
online if you wonder why they're so
short it's just because the price of
buying that airtime for an advertisement
which is what the trailer is it's
basically an ad for the movie is
astronomical it is the most expensive ad
you could possibly buy something during
the Superbowl so those tend to be really
short but it's a lot cheaper for them to
just post stuff online so whatever ends
up dropping I'll do a video for it along
with that you know number 9 Marvel might
also choose to do a guardians of the
galaxy Super Bowl trailer because that's
coming out way sooner is in spider-man
Home Coming Marvel has been a lot
cheaper the way it spends money on stuff
like that so last year there was a bunch
of Super Bowl Captain America Civil War
stuff they'll probably be some similar
Guardian stuff but maybe not quite as
much even if it doesn't drop during the
Super Bowl
they'll be posting stuff online there's
just so many people that are paying
attention to what's happening online
during that weekend that everybody tries
to get in on the action so that's why
everybody makes such a big deal about
Super Bowl trailers number 8 though the
Miles Morales news so they just
confirmed that he's going to get his own
standalone movie they didn't say how
Peter Parker is going to be involved or
what characters though use but the
people that are writing it or the people
that did the lego movie that are doing
the upcoming Han Solo movie so I am
already on board it's going to be
awesome the press release just said that
it's going to be a lot of fun and it
will coexist with the live-action
universe they're talking about the MCU
in the spider-man film so that doesn't
explain a whole lot but just in the name
of
logic and sanity you can pick a couple
things out of that
so most of you probably already know all
about the character is origin but you
have to imagine that a lot of people
have no idea who he is so if you were to
roll up in a spider-man costume they'd
be like why is spider-man's costume
different so whatever they do with the
story the way they market the movie it
will all be to help people understand
and go see it because it'll be like a
big Sony animated feature so number
seven what it seems like they're doing
is just pretending like it's it's own
thing off by itself even though all the
creatives the same with the MCU people
but because it's animated they can do
whatever they want they can get way
crazier but it's not like they're
cheeping out on the live-action film
they spent two hundred and fifty million
dollars making Captain America Civil War
that whole Airport balla scene was
mostly done in a computer that's how
much money they spent on that but
animation is just a lot easier they have
a lot more control over it in the name
of sanity they'll probably choose to do
different villains though so the good
thing about Miles Morales though is he
has pretty much the same group of
villains that Peter Parker had but it's
the ultimate universe so they all look
just a little bit different even though
it's the same basic people but number
six just because this is like a brand
new thing and the character isn't as
well-known as Peter Parker they will
probably do an origin story unlike
spider-man homecoming where he's already
been spider-man for a little while so
the very first big arc Miles Morales had
was ultimate spider-man vol 2 you can
actually go read it if you want but
basically what happened is is Peter
Parker in the Ultimate Universe died and
then a much younger high school age
Miles Morales had looked up to him and
was bitten by a radioactive spider just
like Peter Parker was he got powers
so because Peter had fallen he admired
him so much he took the mantle to honor
him but during his first adventure he
gets his ass hauled in to shield by
Spider Woman saying who the hell are you
in this spider-man costume so all of
Peters friends were just like what the
hell is going on with this kid where did
you get your powers where did you come
from
but then nearby in a separate cell
electro goes hey
starts attacking all the heroes miles
helps take him down so then they start
to trust him he goes back to his family
in the rest of his early arc it just
coming to terms with who his family is
he has criminals in his family his uncle
is the Prowler responsible for the
spider bite they gave him powers in the
first place
and he's just trying to be a kid so it's
kind of like what's happening in the
spider-man homecoming movie so you have
a brand new Spider Man who's still in
high school just trying to figure things
out and still be a kid and hang out with
his friends at the same time in the
funny thing is a lot of you have noticed
that spider-man homecoming has borrowed
a lot of elements from the Miles Morales
comic book so his best friend is Ned
Leeds he looks exactly like Miles
Morales his best friend Genki who's a
completely different character so number
5 what they'll probably do is just adapt
some of that initial origin story run
for Miles Morales and maybe swap in a
couple of different characters just so
they don't end up doing the exact same
people as the spider-man homecoming
movie what I am expecting though is that
the animated Marvel Universe will
aesthetically look very similar to the
live-action universe it's still New York
City so you know what New York City
looks like in the live-action universe
but just like the Netflix shows you go
to different parts of New York City they
all feel very different all the Netflix
shows have a very different tone so I'm
expecting the spider-man homecoming
movie to be the same thing like it will
be spider-man it will still be very
familiar but it'll also have a slightly
different tone even though you're in and
around the same area
speaking of which number four they said
it's going to be a lot of fun I think
that definitely means that they will not
kill Peter Parker to create Miles
Morales so that would be like a slight
change from the comic book origin story
just think about how much of a bummer
note that would be to start on where you
have a bunch of little kids that just
got done seeing Tom Holland in Avengers
infinity war and they see this opening
scroll explaining how spider-man is dead
and he's never coming back you just so
many people would just bail it would be
the worst thing ever
so what they'll probably do is they'll
find a way to include the Peter Parker
character but he will be older the whole
idea is that Miles Morales is the little
kid learning to be spider-man superhero
Peter Parker is this battle-hardened
version of the character and I know I
name-dropped infinity war they haven't
confirmed when this new movie is going
to be released but it'll probably be
sometime in the next year or two just
depending on how long it takes to finish
the animation so I think that it'll drop
some time after infinity work so you'll
have already seen Tom Holland in three
big movies number three what about
villains though who would be the big
villain like I said it's the ultimate
universe he has all the same characters
they would probably just opt to do
ultimate Green Goblin do Norman Osborn
even though when Miles Morales the story
gets started in the comics he's kind of
in prison but it seems like the
spider-man homecoming movie is not going
to do Green Goblin for a long long time
so you want to go with the big villain
that you recognize Green Goblin is the
solid pick but I always get a lot of
questions about this yes I do think that
they will do Green Goblin in the
live-action movies eventually there's
going to be three Tom Hollands
spider-man Home Coming movies
I think they'll definitely get to him
eventually but they're going to take
their time we've already seen two
versions of Norman Osborn in the last
iterations of spider-man so I don't
think they want to go there right away
with this brand-new version of the
character but number two because it's
animation they can actually borrow
actors from the live-action universe so
they haven't confirmed anything about
who's going to be playing who they
haven't cast Miles Morales yet but they
could totally bring Donald Glover back I
don't think that he would play Miles
Morales just because he's a little bit
older they're podcast a little kid to do
the voice in speaking of awesome
spider-man facts did you know that it
was the Russos of Captain America Civil
War they told Dan Harmon to cast Donald
Glover way way back for season one of
community before he blew up and became a
big star so it all comes back around now
Donald Glover in the MCU even though
he's not being directed by the Russos
but it's just funny how things work out
that way so what about the Avengers
though like would they actually have
Avengers from the live-action movies
voice their roles in the animated movie
they could do that but I don't think
that they will and I think they'll try
to keep it as simple as possible even
though the Avengers and all the big
characters will exist in the animated
universe so they'll probably find a way
to include them without doing it in a
way that's going to confuse everyone
that's also seeing
finiti wars that same year where it's
like hey doll these characters are here
how can they also be off an infinity war
doing all this other stuff so they'll
find a really simple way around that but
number one sequels so if this first one
is successful you can expect a Miles
Morales standalone franchise it also
sort of like lives with the Tom Holland
franchise without stepping on its toes
too much but even though they haven't
said what the title is going to be I'm
just expecting them to call it ultimate
spider-man it just don't have a simple
thing ever but they could choose to go
with a different subtitle but let me
know in the comments what do you guys
think about Miles Morales which
characters do you want them to use which
story arc do you want them to adapt in
what do you want them to call the movie
I feel like ultimate spider-man is just
the easiest thing for them to go with
there's a whole bunch of stuff happening
next there's going to be a new Logan
trailer so I'll totally do a video for
that and I'll say congratulations to the
new spider-man giveaway winner Bonnard
you want a $20.00 comiXology gift card
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details I'm still trying to
slowly hypnotize people into reading
more comic books so new logan trailer
coming in a little while
well you guys wait for that to post you
can click here to learn all about
Deadpool 2 and you can click here to
rewatch that injustice 2 trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight